- Did you have any idea how bad
things would get at Memorial?
- Nobody knew.
- In this particular story,
the physical space is such
an important character.
That's why we spent the time
on these sets
to make them reflect
the actual spaces
that these people
had to live in.
What really sets these sets
apart from a lot of other sets
is the--the sheer scope and size
of them.
- Yeah. Wow.
- Yeah.
- The fidelity to details
is just stunning.
The exterior, the way
that the windows are broken,
the--this is just amazing.
Hurricane Katrina hit,
and I think it was a shock
to all of us
who did
international response work,
we kind of assumed that if there
was a big crisis in the U.S.,
naively, it turns out, that
our infrastructure would hold up
in a better way
than in some countries
that didn't have as big
of national, you know, GDP
or were seen as low-income
or less resourced,
and the shock of Katrina
for a lot of Americans
was that, no, we have
huge vulnerabilities,
but the vulnerabilities,
the inability to mount
an effective response
to a crisis was
pretty important to note,
and I felt at that point,
I'd worked in foreign disasters
that it was important to look
at my own country.
- This building can take
these winds.
- It's been here 80 years.
It can take it.
Only thing to worry about,
worst case--severe flood.
- Okay.
If there was severe flooding,
I mean, what would we do?
- We'd have to evacuate.
- Evacuate?
How?
- Well, I don't know how.
I mean,
you're the incident commander.
- Not only are you a reporter
for "The New York Times"
and an incredible journalist,
but you're also
a medical doctor.
- I actually did an MD
and a PhD,
a combined program, and the idea
was to be a clinician...
- Mm-hmm.
- ...practicing medicine,
and also do research
that related to that topic
and try to, you know,
do independent investigating.
It all kind of started
with a year off,
or what I envisioned
to be a year off
between med school
and residency,
and then my life went
in a very different direction.
- You went to Bosnia, right?
- I ended up getting sent
to the border
of Kosovo and Macedonia
when refugees were fleeing
across that border,
and I found myself as a--
as a novice doctor
being put in charge of triage
as medics or just people brought
people with various crises
to this tent--
this small tent
that was serving 100,000 people.
- So that point in your life
where you're having
to make decisions about who gets
medical care and who doesn't,
I mean, that seems
very connected
to the story
of "Five Days at Memorial."
How did you first discover
this story of--
of what happened
at Memorial Hospital?
- I happened to be volunteering
in New Orleans
after Hurricane Katrina,
and first I went
with a public health team,
and we worked in the shelters
where the individuals who had
been displaced from their homes.
There were still people packed
into stadiums,
and we were doing
some public health research,
looking at whether people
had medical issues
in these vast shelters
that needed attention,
and we found a lot of them
and information
for future responses.
And then I think I started
hearing about this rumor
that these unusual deaths
had occurred at Memorial.
Just like anybody else,
I'm sure I heard it on the news.
I had just written this book
about a Bosnian war hospital
that was under siege
for two years,
and never had I heard
of doctors, nurses
getting so desperate
that they even talked
about ending patients' lives.
- So there's the chapel
where they put all the bodies.
Whoa. What's...
- The chapel.
It's just very, very real
to life,
and this chapel was, um, a site
where the bodies were placed
and blessed,
and it's really something
to see it in this way.
- Yeah.
- I think it will have
quite an impact
when people watch the show.
The reason that I wanted to look
at the individual actions
is that I had seen,
as a responder myself
in disaster
and conflict situations that
very often our infrastructure
doesn't hold up,
very often, we individuals,
you, me,
might be left in a situation
where our ability to act,
our decisions,
could have
life and death consequences
because rarely, rarely does
a response go as one would hope.
- I think one of the things
that you did in the book
that John and I, you know,
instantly latched on to
was that it was nonjudgmental,
that it was really
a presentation
of all sides of the story.
- I start letting everybody
in your unit know
that there aren't any more
National Guard trucks coming,
and they're pulling the rest
of their people out.
- What about our people?
- You are seeing these events
from multiple perspectives
who are very valid because
depending on where you are
in this massive
2-city block hospital,
you are having
a different experience,
so there are many truths,
actually,
many, many realities,
and it felt really important
to portray those.
- We're running
out of food and water.
There's the constant sound
of misery.
We can't take it much longer.
- When I wrote this,
and very much the same
as when you and John wrote,
is that we want people
to experience this or to--
to go along with it
as it happened in time,
not just to look back and judge
but to try to march through
moment by moment
along with people who didn't
have perfect information,
who were basically
dealing with the situation
as it unfolded
and to have that empathy
for them
and maybe understanding of--
of what led to
the events that occurred
that were so shocking.
- Really,
right from the very beginning
as we were talking about
how to adapt the book,
we wanted to try to advocate
for all of our characters,
and we really wanted to feel
like every character
in the story
believed in what
they were doing.
- And action.
- We're getting out
all the patients that we can.
- Our hope is, like, that we'd
be left to debate and discuss
some of the ethics
and issues involved
and really hope that this would
provoke conversations
after people watched it about
some of the questions raised.
- I've tried to do good.
- Is this person guilty?
Is this person not guilty?
- Jesus.
- Should this person
have gone to jail?
- I need to go back upstairs.
I need to check on a patient.
- Anything you need to know,
you can email
our corporate office.
- Why? Your office is--
we're a different hospital.
- We're evacuating.
You need to go. Now.
- Was it understandable
and justifiable what they did?
Is it even possible for us
to pass judgment
on these characters
from the comfort of hindsight?
- I think it's absolutely fine
that individuals will watch this
and come away
with different conclusions
about what they feel,
you know, should have happened,
but what I really want
is for them to understand
what did happen,
to have the facts--
that's very material,
and--and that helps us
understand
and make informed kind of
judgments in our own mind.
I think as human beings,
we have an aversion
to, you know, really embracing
the possibility
that the worst case scenario
will happen.
It's, like, natural.
We don't wanna go there,
but also, more broadly,
to invest in things
that are rare but foreseeable
as potential threats,
like a flood in New Orleans...
- Yeah.
- ...and could be catastrophic.
But what I think
we can do validly,
and--and all of us who--
who watch this or read the book
can do and should do
is think not,
like, "What would I have done?"
because we can't know that,
but what would I want to do?
- This is why this is such
a timely story,
'cause it's not just about
this little piece of history.
I think it speaks to something
so much larger.
I hope that they will empathize
with the people
who actually went through this,
and I hope that people will
come away with an understanding
of why it is important
that we think about crises
before they happen.
- We all know that now...
- Yeah.
...with COVID, but that takes
some investment
on a personal level.
- And you're just looking
at one hospital
in the middle of this
whole hurricane and flooding
and all the situation.
It's so metaphoric for
all the things that went on
in the city, on the state level,
on the federal level,
and people who were displaced
were often
the most disadvantaged.
- And, really, my passion
for telling stories like this
is because these inequities,
these structural issues
are with us all the time.
When do we stand
and pay attention to them?
We need to learn
from our history, right?
That's the purpose.
Our hope is that we'd be left
to debate and discuss
some of the ethics and issues
and some
of the questions raised.